people around the world are riding high
speed trains have you heard planning
missions to the moon and dreaming a
flying cars yeah we are so next week
we're bringing you a special series of
reports we call it world of motion a
team of correspondents traveled Japan
Greece southern Africa and Scotland to
discover how and why people are on the
move why didn't I get one of those not
many of us travel because we have to for
our daily commute others see it as a
gateway to opportunity adventure and
even salvation we'll go around by train
plane boat and car to show you our world
of motion
[Music]
I'm Michelle Miller at New York's Penn
Station where the morning rush is the
busiest in America and I'm rainy
Inocencio in Tokyo where the high-speed
trains or the Shinkansen are the most
efficient in the world
we're gonna run the numbers and ride the
rails to see which country whose
passengers best that's coming up on CBS
this morning
I'm Roxana Saberi off the coast of
lesbos Greece where the number of
refugees and migrants trying to cross
this sea from Turkey is rising but now
this is the only NGO left here with the
rescue boat to save them if they make
the dangerous dream Mozambique is one of
the poorest countries in the world which
is why this bridge and the road leading
from it could provide a much-needed
economic boost for the country I'm
Debora patta
I'll show you how businesses at once
inaccessible areas of booming and the
unintended benefits for smugglers what
the Royal Air Force is doing high above
the skies of Scotland to get some pretty
extraordinary kids a new outlook on life
I'm Charlie d'Agata that's coming up
next week on CBS this morning
hey we are everywhere our four-part
series world of motion will start Monday
on CBS this morning I heard you say
Anthony why didn't I get that assignment
because you're needed right here at the
table that's why it looks so it doesn't
move quickly there does look good